[Music]
stories about the alien newspaper
business usually feature fabulously
wealthy benefactors asserting good
intentions as the heroes keeping the
lights on
this is jeff bezos and the washington
post biotech billionaire patrick
sunchong and los angeles times
and lauren powell jobs the widow of
steve jobs and the majority owner of the
atlantic but the reality is somewhat
different today about half of america's
newspapers are controlled by private
equity hedge funds and other investment
groups which have been rapidly
consolidating the industry since the
post-2008 financial crisis
one name stands above the rest olden
global capital the new york hedge fund
is notoriously private but since 2007
olden its top executives have brought
increasingly bigger and bigger regional
titles including chicago tribune denver
post and boston herald those purchases
numbering in the hundreds have brought
greater attention from u.s officials
labor unions media watchdogs and
disgruntled journalists
the main complaint
stop destroying local newspapers olden
has been accused of whittling down the
companies it buys with a brutally
efficient zero-based budgeting strategy
straight from the playbook of wall
street's most feared activist investors
the alden recipe get rid of the newsroom
and sell the real estate helping recoup
the purchase price of the newspaper then
go through every line item in the
paper's expense sheet and make cuts
layoffs have become the norm the result
ghost newspapers unable to produce much
in the way of original local journalism
heath freeman the president of olden
doesn't see it that way though he
believes he's the one saving newspapers
that would otherwise be forced to shut
down oldham capital isn't the only
player in the ghost newspaper trade
small and mid-sized regional and local
newspapers have long been treated as a
distressed asset class and bounced
around by investors for short-term
profits fortress investment group which
is controlled by softbank and chatham
asset management are all challenging
olden for a spot on the throne as the
leading guardian or destroyer of
newspapers
[Music]
you